some great things I'm sure if coming
your life by playing the flash rings but
I would think there'd be a downside
which is that you're out in the world
you're well known for playing the flash
I've got to think there are drunken
people to like a bit of a faster than
you flash yes I'm challenged to race is
that true people come up and challenge
you to race well never stranger I've had
a good friend of mine who to be honest
is like tiny and like should have
assumed that I could have beat him that
I was faster than right and then crew
members to different crew members these
are adults yes should know that you play
the flash and they use special effects
and they're still like I bet I could
beat the flag yeah yeah I'm through you
know you still have one that's fantastic
and what's that you know what's
interesting when you watch the show is
they do a special thing that you never
see your feet know so I'm wondering are
you actually running in those scenes
because it's this blur mm-hmm so maybe
you don't even have to be running I
don't know we used to you know I season
one we'd put me on a treadmill
with a harness and then I realized on
the show that it was always like a
waster shot and that my legs weren't in
frame so they were they had me running
for and no reason whatsoever so that
just sounds like a cruel practical joke
so now I know I need to be really
running just keep doing it yeah so now
they frame it out I'm literally just
moving like that see that might show me
show me what you're doing cool we can
literally hear be tasting you can see
been chasing it
do it again do it again in the red
chasing you see I wouldn't even do that
well yeah it's all about the arms all
about it would great that looks like one
of those really early bad sixties dances
that didn't catch on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you